foreign
as I discussed at the beginning of the
show if you're just picking up with us
um a couple of these calls on this
episode I blew it one of them I got
involved in the actual dysfunction of
the marriage relationship and I got
carried away I allowed that to happen
and so I ended up getting frustrated
with the caller I ended up missing a
crucial piece of wisdom
in this particular call you're about to
hear it's Anna from Tulsa and Anna has a
son
um And that son watched her his father
kill somebody
and
I've got stuff going on in my private
life I've been on the road I haven't
been taking care of myself very well my
diet is about that of a second grader
turned loose in his parents pantry and
um
I was immediately thrown back to some of
those crisis calls that I went on with
especially with kids especially with
kids that saw things that they should
never have seen kids trying to make
sense of awful things that their moms or
dads had done either to them or to
somebody else
and so you're going to hear in this call
I Stumble through it a lot and I get
quiet a lot and I just there's long gaps
where I don't say anything
um and
again normally we would edit this stuff
out or I wouldn't have taken the call
it's rare that I blow it this bad but I
thought it was important this time for
this one reason
if somebody comes to you with some hard
information and it's not a good time
it's always okay to say hey I really
want to be there for you I need 30
minutes I really want to be there for
you I can't meet right this second can
we meet at 5 pm tonight can we meet
after the kids are in bed gonna take you
to breakfast in the morning
so this is me being vulnerable this is
me showing you um man sometimes I step
up to the plate and I just miss
um and um this isn't a a pivotal moment
in Anna's life
and um
I showed up but I wasn't fully there
check it out
go to Anna
Anna Tulsa what's up Anna
hi Dr
today rocking on how are you
pretty good
10 year old son after a huge live change
he witnessed his father commits a brutal
crime and
um
his father will be gone for a long time
and I know
well he committed murder in front of him
who'd he kill
Ed
um he found his
longtime girlfriend in bed with the band
the band and
it was the next door neighbor
please
what a mess
how many years did he get
it's it's still going so
so before we go any further can I just
tell you I'm sorry I'm so sorry your
whole world's exploded I'm so sorry
thank you
and I know you love your little boy he's
on the phone with us right now we can
talk about him in a minute but I'm just
so sorry
nothing's ever going to be the same and
you didn't ask for this and didn't I'm
so so I'm just so sorry
foreign
yeah it's uh it was definitely
unexpected and that's the most Oklahoma
thing I've ever heard somebody say I'm
like well it was just unexpected
it was a
nuclear bomb that went off in your
neighborhood and it detonated directly
in your house and I'm so sorry
my gosh
what a mess
for those of you listening
um
I find to walk into that home too many
times and hugged too many Annas over the
course of my career and so I'm kind of
speechless right now just because I know
it's next
um
okay I'm not gonna put my story under
your story Anna so let's talk about you
how however when did this happen
uh at the beginning of December
so we've had a little bit of time to
well I was about to say this is like
yesterday you've had no time
he he's adjusting well
um you know why because he's he's 10.
yeah that's why I'm worried about you
and I want to go out on a limb just by
talking to you saying you're struggling
is that right
yeah that's right it sounds really like
your ability to toggle in and out of
being unable to breathe and you feel
like if you start crying you're never
gonna be able to stop to it's okay it's
great
pretty much
if you I can't tell you how to grieve
because everybody does it differently
but I want to tell you the longer that
goes
the deeper those grooves get man that
gets real hard
and I know you feel like you have to be
the rock in the wind for your son and
there's some truth to that somebody's
got to make sure he eats and is fed and
he's still got connectivity especially
after the hell he's been through and
Hell he's going to go through
but the greatest gift he could ever have
in the world right now is a mom that's
honest with herself and with him and
with the world around her okay
yeah
he's gonna need a a strong balance of
stability
and he's going to need a mom who tells
him the truth when she's devastated and
heartbroken okay okay
don't hide your grief from him it's a
gift it'll be a great gift to him
[Music]
okay
that's my promise my promise my promise
my promise
God I'm so sorry
how you
say you say it's been been a while it's
been it hasn't it's been like a few a
month two months right two and a half
months
um
has your son been asked to testify yet
he has been and that's that's kind of
where my my question really is is how do
we handle that because his his
grandmother his paternal grandmother is
trying to
she's trying to manipulate his testimony
and
um get her as far away from that boy as
possible yeah there's an order in place
now so good good
it's just hard with his questions you
know like when can I go see them when
can I you know
oh man okay
um let's walk through this from the tip
top okay
he's gonna always know
that half of him is Mommy and half of
him is Daddy
okay
in the dance you're gonna have to do is
gonna be a difficult one
because
you're gonna have to let him know that I
loved your dad but I did not love what
like what he did and he's gonna he got
in big trouble for what he did because
what he did was wrong
but the moment that switches to I hate
him
I'll never love him again I'm pissed off
at him he ruined our lives that 10 year
old boys can internalize that because
half of him is that guy
and then on the other hand you got
grandparents telling them how great he
was and it was just a moment of whatever
and it was for self-defense it was a
moment of passion
and so he's going to be thinking yeah
it's I guess I guess the scariest most
sickest moment of my life was from a
good guy see how confused this little
boy is you're right
oh man
so
he's gonna need in short order like
today tomorrow right and this isn't all
fall on you this falls on some
caregivers and that's why I can't stand
it when adults act like idiots like his
grandpa like his grandparents are
well and you know I can't call them
idiots because they are trying they love
their son and they're they're in the
same I get it
um he's gonna have to know
that he is wonderful and magical and
able to overcome things but he can't
just get that with words
what does that mean that means you're
gonna have to give him a bunch of little
opportunities to be successful and so
are his teachers and so are his aunts
and uncles that you trust and so are
friends of parent uh parents friends
he's got to have chores he's gonna have
to have a bunch of little wins and when
he has success in little places everyone
needs to Rally around and point it out
look what you did great job look how
hard you tried
all right right and if we just wrap our
arms around him and tell him you're so
wonderful and great and perfect and
lovely and all that
there's going to be a disconnect and
what his body feels and what his brain
knows
so it's got to be through accountability
it's got to be through action okay
whether that's a jointed Jiu Jitsu or
playing baseball or whatever and you're
gonna have to be prepared for him to
love love love his dad and be so mad at
you that he can't go see him every day
and then in short order hate his dad so
much that he can't breathe
and then go right back to loving dad
because he can't hit him too much
because that means he hates himself do
you see I mean it's just it's gonna be a
dance from here out right right
um
a friend of mine
who does this for a living works with
these kids
um she's just a savant she's been on the
show actually
um
everybody's going to want to get to your
kid because he's a prosecutor's dream
and he's a defense attorney's nightmare
right
yeah has he already testified or is it
coming up or how's that working
[Music]
in the court yet they're still working
on that process but he's already done an
interview
and did you interview with the with the
psychologist or with the judge in his
Chambers or her
um he did he did um
well they started with
going and and the prosecutor said that
that is uh gonna be strong in the case
because they just don't want he hasn't
really talked about it and they don't
they want when it happens to be as
organic as possible
and so
he hasn't really spoke about it or
anything
um he has a therapist he's going to
weekly but that's still they're still
building a relationship so um I would
write this down tfcbt
trauma-focused cognitive behavioral
therapy
it's extraordinary and it's actually
pretty systematic
um and what it does is it teaches him
how to feel safe in his body when his
body sounds every freaking alarm that it
has which it will
because there's going to be moments of
Terror and rage and self-hatred and
hatred of dad and hatred of you and
hatred of everybody
and that little body doesn't know how to
handle all that and so what
trauma-focused cognitive behavioral
therapy does it teaches kids how to take
deep breaths and how to lengthen the gap
between stimulus and response and how to
feel safe in your own body and what to
do when you don't feel safe so it's a
lot of skills he's going to learn in a
pretty systematic way
um
and if it's possible there in Tulsa
where you live I would seek that out
okay okay
um
[Music]
what's and I feel like I'm just talking
man I'm making your story mine I've just
been through down this road so much and
it's just so heartbreaking for me and I
know it's heartbreaking for you you're
living in how I mean you're
I mean your your glasses are tinted in
red and fire because you're living in
hell
um any specific questions I can help
with I feel like I'm just rambling I'm
so sorry
no but I appreciate everything you've
said it's been very insightful in the
situation
um my my big question is
when
this is over with and he has been
sentencing everything how do I talk
about because I've already set the
boundary I'm not taking him to visit in
the jail and I'm not going to uh
entertain phone conversations where he
he's trying to put stuff in his head and
so I want to just be able to to I was
thinking okay well you can write letters
and then when you're 18 we can give them
to Dad or you know if Dad wants to write
letters I'll give them to him when he's
18 but I just want to make sure that
he feels like he's being heard because
now you know his dad is gone yeah
um so part of the boundary is keeping
your kids safe
and if in short order or if over time
there is an understanding if your
husband is able to say or your
ex-husband are y'all divorced now
we were never married okay all right so
um if he is able to say things like
Daddy really messed up big time
and I hurt somebody really bad
and so I had to go away
if he takes ownership for the fracture
in the relationship
that's the sign that
um I will entertain some communication
okay but if there's some I got screwed
you see what I'm saying he needs to own
dad and son are not together because of
something dad did not son
and I don't think he's there yet and I
don't think he will be for a couple
years that's and that's his choice and
and I think in a way to articulate that
doesn't mean you get the phone doesn't
mean you get
um a bunch of visits
uh right up front
um
what you don't want to do is be the
person that
is so enraged by what he did and so
enraged by the embarrassment and the
shame and all that stuff and how he blew
your life up and blew your son's life up
that when he's able to say
this is 100 on me and son I'm looking at
you and I'm proud of you and I believe
in you and you're not going to be like
me
when he can say those words those words
will be
um Like Oxygen in that little boy's
lungs
but it also takes a sense of maturity
that
somebody who hauls off and just kills
the neighbor doesn't might not have
right
and so I think you're wise to not allow
connection right now and I think you're
wise to allow letters and I would allow
letters and read the letters and if
there's nothing bogus or dumb in them I
miss you son and I can't wait to see you
someday and all that kind of well I
don't know yeah I'm thinking out loud
um you know what I'm just an idiot on a
podcast work with a psychologist on that
um I'm I'm
angry right now on your behalf and so
it's clouding my judgment a little bit
because my thoughts right now is that
guy deserves to never talk to that
little boy ever ever again as long as he
lives
and I want that boy to not know that man
ever existed except he can't because
it's his daddy and he probably looks
just like him and he saw everything that
happened
yeah and and you know if he writes
letters and he does
take ownership then I think that would
be a different story it's just when he
has done this and then he talks on the
phone about how he wants his mom to to
get our son to manipulate the testimony
it just it confuses me so bad because I
don't understand how you would you would
you know first you've committed this act
in front of him and now you're trying to
to re-traumatize him and you know
convince him that he didn't see
everything that he saw right
yeah he used to be as far away from that
man as possible
that means lost the right to
um have have connection with the son
and I'm not saying that's forever but
that's certainly for the foreseeable
future try to weaponize a kid after what
you did to him God help you man
I'll tell you this
um it's going to be very easy to go to
autopilot
please fight that with all you can
what that means is you're gonna have to
feel this and it's gonna be
unimaginable pain
foreign
you can't do it by yourself
do you believe me when I say that
do you believe me
I do believe okay
so hear me say the greatest gift you can
get your son is for you to get a couple
of good friends for you to get a
counselor for you to get some friends at
your church I don't wherever you've got
people and set up a regular time that
you can meet and even if it's two or
three girlfriends that you text and say
hey
I'm gonna need you to speak openly and
to word vomit sometimes
and I'm gonna need someone to walk
alongside me I've picked you all two or
three or four if y'all are in every
Monday at 10 or whatever every Tuesday
at whatever time
if y'all will be there for me as often
as you can I'd be eternally grateful
okay I can do that and you keep showing
up and you keep showing up and you keep
showing up
and you'll ask each other what's one
thing you did good for yourself this
week which one thing you're grateful for
what's one thing you are just devastated
heartbreaking for
because you're gonna have to fight the
urge to check out to just numb through
this because it's going to hurt that bad
and if the defense attorney's doing
their job their job is to
make the world believe your ten-year-old
son is a liar
and it will make you feel and see rage
like you've probably never experienced
in your life
and if he has a your son has a good
attorney then their job is to defend him
from that nonsense and that evil
right
let me say it this way let me see it
this way
everything in your life is different now
and the sooner
um imagine your house caught on fire
and all of a sudden the ceiling starts
caving in
and you put up one hand to try to stop
it and then all of a sudden the beam
starts falling over here and so you
reach up over there and then the floor
starts bubbling up and you've got one
foot like over you know trying to keep
the floor up
the sooner you just get out of the house
and let it go to Ash
which is where it's headed and then you
can start the cleanup process and start
imagining what's life going to be like
now
it's not any easier
but it's a whole lot less psychological
Devastation because you don't have you
don't have all that wasted energy trying
to hold this thing together everything's
new now okay
that makes sense
and it's okay to be so mad
so mad
and so heartbroken and so everything
that little boy's gonna need the word
the nerd word reuses Attunement um
attachment he's gonna need to know that
his mommy sees his eyes and feels his
heart
and that he can see her eyes and feel
her heart even when her heart is sad
okay okay
and I keep saying this I'm so sorry
as you'll head through this process
um please please please
um don't hesitate to call keep him away
from media keep him away from
well-meaning aunts and uncles if you do
have aunts and uncles come over or
friends or whoever feel free to say
do not talk about Dad don't say you look
just like him don't say so glad that
you're not whatever or nothing he's not
mentioned in this house right now the
only person with permission to mention
Dad is is your little boy that's it
and we're not we're keeping from yeah so
keep away from media
keep up the good work with him and
counseling
and make sure you take care of yourself
I'll be with you every step of the way
call anytime I can help I'm so so sorry
my goodness